I always felt grateful for even the
small things grateful be grateful
grateful be grateful be grateful be
grateful
hello believe nation today we're going
to talk about how you can be grateful as
usual as you watch the video if there's
something somebody says that really
resonates with you leave it in the
comments and put it in quotes so others
can be inspired by it as well and whilst
attitude is one of the most strongest
forms of power and attracting good
things you know if you truly feel
grateful for the things in your life
I always feel grateful for even the
small things I always used to celebrate
the small things now I might be
celebrating the bigger things but I
always celebrate every little good thing
that would happen to me in my life even
before I had any kind of money or any
that I would celebrate and I would feel
grateful for it and it just gave me more
and this is exactly the same thing
that's happening right now I still
remain grateful and more Combes there
were a lot of mixed feelings after that
race I wasn't happy with the time but
afterwards like I saw the time I was
like man that's really like I'm not
happy with that and then I realized that
I had made my fifth Olympic team and you
know that was something that after
London I didn't think as possible I'm
taking some time off going through some
ups and downs and being able to get
through the obstacles that I had to be
able to have the chance to swim on my
fifth Olympic team it's just special to
not only be on the team again and
represent my country but also have the
chance to have my son come and watch my
last films ever he might not remember
him but I'll have the memories for life
I know really truly had a lot of genius
I'm very clearly not gifted and I know
that the position I've reached is a
position that should be given to a
genius it's not i-it's not deservingly
so so the reason I'm good to fans or I
believe in them is because one I'm
employed by them so I'm like thank you
guys you think
so I'm returning that kindness or the
second way to look at if it is that okay
listen I'm really scared don't go
anywhere because I know I don't deserve
it but thank you so much so in hasta con
I'm just being I'm already saying I'm
being kind to them for my own selfish
gains but whatever the case I'm
immensely grateful I think it comes out
of gratitude it doesn't come out of any
other reason if I see on weekends I have
hundreds of people outside my house
today Sunday and a lot of people will
come out in the evening and I feel like
going and meeting them all my security
with the gun says don't but I want to
meet them because you know I'm like I
have to thank them so I think fans are
like how you feel in front of an ocean
you know sometimes when you are so full
of yourself you go down on a beach and
stand in front of the sea and realize
how insignificant you are and you know
all the importance in your house and
your well upholstered rules and your
louisvil Thrones and your you know BMWs
and you're like oh god I'm so powerful
and then you go and stand in front of
the sea and you realize you're such an
insignificant nobody in the larger
scheme of things a fans to me are like
that see when I see them I realize my
insignificance without them I want to go
and stand with them and say okay I'm
insignificant but thank you for making
me so significant for making me so
special have you ever been really
frustrated and making a really big deal
out of something in your life and then
something happens and everything gets
put into perspective I had that today I
was frustrated with an issue in my life
and I was really struggling with how to
move forward what to do about it
and it wasn't that big of a deal except
I was making it a big deal kind of been
there making little things and the big
things and then I got a cell phone call
from a friend of mine that I hadn't
heard from probably six months to a year
we weren't really close but we were
friends we'd hung out several times
and the phone call is interesting
something was different about his voice
he was a little slower and it sounds
slurred and then he proceeded to tell me
he had experienced a stroke
now he's a young guy so this is a really
unique issue and he had to go into the
hospital for a month and he lost his
ability to speak for some time and he
had challenges walking and he had to
learn how to do certain things all over
again and it was almost embarrassing how
trivial of a problem I was dealing with
in comparison to what my friend was
dealing with and it gave me such a
matter of perspective I mean I was in a
position where I thought oh it's not
fair I'm frustrated with this area of my
life and then BOOM the reality check was
written and cashed and I realized I
didn't have it that bad I was making a
little deal into a big deal I need to
chill out because whatever it is you're
frustrated with there's a high high
percentage that you're making a big deal
out of something that's not we usually
come together in life to deal with the
big stuff and we bond through the big
stuff it's the little stuff that gets us
off track so I asked you today what
thing or things are you making a really
big deal that really aren't and what
would what could happen in your life
that would automatically change
everything and you would be begging for
those problems again and you don't want
to manifest that you don't to create
that
but that that perspective that knowing
that your life could change on a dime
for the worse so then you need to be
grateful for the problems that you have
right now because you don't want to
treat them in flicker you don't want to
treat them in four horrific challenges
which oftentimes can happen so I
encourage you to be very grateful for
what you have today enjoy your problems
for the size that they are they could
always be much more painful and truly
take refuge in the fact that you have a
very good life if you're able to sit
around and watch a video blog
you maybe have your sight ability your
sound your ability to hear what I'm
saying auditory wise you have so much
more in your life then you're giving
yourself awareness too then I ask that
you wake up to that waking up every
morning and figuring out even in a
difficult situation where the pieces of
gratitude are so like coming into the
city yesterday or the day before I was
stuck in traffic and I was late for
something and I was like oh you got to
go faster but this is an opportunity for
a difficult to solve a difficult
gratitude problem which is it's the city
I'm going to is so amazing and wonderful
that everyone else wants to be here even
faster than me so I'm grateful to be
going into this city do you have time to
even think about like where you are in
the award season at this point where or
is it time to dress for the Golden
Globes and it's two days before that's
two days from now I know I don't
who's gonna come to your house and give
you a dress somebody's doing that get it
work out okay
it always works out it always works out
but no I mean I think it's only because
it was a publicist before and for
whatever thoughts I used to have about
how much that was waste of time mm-hmm I
should've been making films I started
too late you know should have come to
NYU or Howard film school and learned
all this and I should have you know
realized what I wanted to do earlier I
started making films in my relief
mid-30s I was a publicist you know what
I mean the odds that that was ever gonna
work and I'd ever be sitting here with
you that I'd be here on opening day
today's opening their vision the last
film that I just III had in theaters I
distributed myself on 22 screens now
it's on 2,300 screens with Paramount
Pictures who used to be my client like
that that stuff only just puts me in a
place of just being grateful that I got
to make the phone and I continue to be
able to make films of the dresses and
the numbers and then all that stuff is
just less important to me be grateful be
happy and enjoy this because it's not
promised who knows where we're gonna be
in a year two years three years we're at
this position now and I don't want to
look back and be like you had it all and
you weren't even present for it you
weren't able to enjoy it I want to be
here be now and and be grateful we were
talking about this outside in the
hallway about you know do you want
because we're talking about Shawn about
how sometimes you you can love what you
do and be good at it but sometimes you
don't have to love what you do and still
be good at that's shown in acting yeah
we were having this discussion out there
and I and and right now you know not
everything is great you know I certainly
want things I fight for things to be
better and I fight to do things better
in myself but I also feel like I've been
given so much opportunity that you even
start to whiff of a sort of wine or
complain as certain other people do I
know whining complaining and complaining
hosts the I feel that it's listen to my
song someone like that I shoot him but I
I so I feel like I the best thing that I
can do is be grateful and and honor it
and continue to try to do the best work
I can and and I'm fortunate that you
know every time you know someone says oh
no he's not the right guy for that and
I'm able to go out and and prove that I
can do it the big breakthrough was in
1986 you're on with Johnny Carson first
time with Johnny Carson and he loved you
you did a routine about calling God in
the phone right I think you put your on
hold
didn't he well it was a big place you
know people talk about praying and
talking to God all the time but I just
thought it would be great if you could
have a phone conversation if you could
actually just reach God somehow if you
could just pick up the phone and call
God if you were calling God today what
would you say thank you alright just I
got nothing but gratitude my whole life
my whole life is just I'm so blessed I'm
so lucky and I feel it every day
do you ever crave the anonymity you had
as a child when you closed the news oh
boy no no like a taco so pasaron asleep
Aquitania gay
Casey Racine Omar Pinto de nada
Quintero a racy Simone Barcelona Poe
pork on Sharan me Gwen Dara cuando era
muy Chico poor Dom a la / - need IE y
para ser mejor que soy thank you guys so
much for watching I hope you enjoyed the
video I'd love to know what did you
think are you gonna be more grateful now
in your business what lessons did you
learn leave it in the comments and I'm
gonna join in the discussion I also want
to give a quick shout-out to Janina Lea
Del Rio thank you so much for buying my
book it really means a lot to me
those are you watching you want to
chance at a shout out in their future
video make sure to pick up a copy and
email in your receipt so we can keep
track thank you guys so much for
watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
where it is and I'll see you soon